right come june 1st businesses will be
able to operate
like normal cobit 19 restrictions will
be lifted in clark county and that means
businesses need to prepare joe mohler is
live at firefly restaurant on paradise
near twain with what business owners
there have to say
joe denise i'm sure we can all agree
that it has been one long year and it's
exciting to get things back to normal
but businesses like firefly here
um they need to hire more people so they
can keep up with the demand they just
open their doors here about an hour ago
now firefly was closed for six months
and just
reopened this week now the owner says
they need more workers
a lot of the people that are opening new
businesses and stuff are having trouble
and you know i'm having a little trouble
too i mean i would like to open for
brunch
but um short a couple cooks right now
john simmons owns firefly a few blocks
away from the strip they are looking to
hire more people and are even doing
bonuses for people they bring on
with restrictions gone come june 1st in
clark county
that means larger events and no capacity
limits michelle rothstein from balloons
with a twist says she is ready
already seeing a business pick up and
she's eager for conventions and larger
events
as we're noticing a surge in bookings
right now
we're starting to hire more people back
so it's kind of finding that balance
between
more bookings um and finding more people
because we need to
make sure that everything's balanced
correctly
and on the strip treasure island is
actively hiring gillies and looking
forward to reopening their dance for
also chao mexican kitchen on the link
promenade they plan to bring back
latin night they too are hiring now back
out here live you're taking a look at
the
the bartenders here at the bar and
firefly they just opened about an hour
ago so
um many places are in need of workers
and there's so many places that are
hiring that it's making it difficult for
places like this to get
more employees through the door but all
the business owners that i did talk to
agreed they are excited to see las vegas
come back to life
reporting near paradise and twain joe
mullen